you turn on the tv look at the ads  when's the last time you saw biracial  couples on tv when's the last time you  saw the way i mean people are selling  products they do ads to sell products we  haven't been able to communicate it in a  way that is  uh mike might say another way well see  that's kind of perfect yeah well i've  been able to communicate but look how  the press has changed  what the hell are you talking about  so that was a collection of sentences  that were started and then abandoned  before he finished them sometimes i'll  start a sentence and i don't even know  where it's going i just totally find it  along the way he's got no  sense of of even what decade we're  living in so he says when's the last  time he saw a biracial couple in an  advertisement a better question is  when's the last time you saw a straight  white couple in a tv commercial  it's uh it is  embarrassing and it's it's  long since gotten to the point where  it's really not funny anymore